hi there I'm an oppressor Robinson for
GameSpot here on the frontline at San
Diego comic-con 2014 right now I am
standing on a rooftop at Nerdist HQ and
we're going to play some laser tag but
we're gonna do it borderland style so
let's check in with some of the people
that are gonna be playing with us and
you can check out some of my awesome
awesome
laser tag skills what's your name
Bryce Bryce are we going to win this
match of lazer absolutely what's gonna
be our strategy what do you think should
we be super aggressive or like hide a
lot in a hammer as much as we can
stealth is a key have one person just
flank them from behind I'm a pretty good
sniper maybe I should just hide out find
a high spot and just you know take it
out I think that'll be my strategy are
you an experienced laser tagger laser
tag bother it but definitely Borderlands
play it all the time
I'm Anna what's your name Cajun Cajun uh
I'm sorry that we have to fight each
other in the in the arena I feel like
I'm going to take you down what do you
think I'm sorry I won't be able to use
you as a human shield so I think your
chances are good if you aim high but
I'll be down low where no one can shoot
me I've got I've got the the height
advantage I think here I got over the
top of the barriers that's true that's
true
so um do you have any experience with
Borderlands lots of experience actually
yes hey it's one of your favorite games
one of my top 5 of all time yes I love
first-person shooters and this one
really set the bar high for other ones
for fun excitement and uniqueness
regardless of whether I got the most
kills which it probably did who knows
but I I at least feel like I played a
good support role for my team let a
kamikaze mission across the battlefield
feeling pretty good about my performance
here in the borderlands let me know what
you think do you think you could have
gotten more kills than me if you want to
challenge me to some laser tag sometime
totally up for it tweet at me on my
fancy new Samsung Galaxy s5 and let me
know what you think